a new opinion piece calling out that
meeting by the way Among Us and Mexican
leaders discussing the Border crisis the
brutal headline Mexico's president rolls
Biden gives us worse than nothing on
Border Texas congresswoman Beth vany
member of the ways and means and small
business committees joins me now um
thank you so much for joining us today
during this week's Mexico visit
Secretary of State blinkin called on
Mexico to help end what he calls a quote
irregular migration regular is an
understatement uh Republicans are
obviously tearing into that meeting as
should every American uh with some
calling it all talk no action and too
little too late and I'd like to know
where in the world was
kamla oh that's a great question as our
as our borders are why was she not down
there talking about what's going out
that border it's a great question I
can't answer it but we have been saying
this this whole week well as soon as we
found that this meeting was scheduled
it's great to go down there and talk to
the president you know of Mexico but
what's your plan what's your demand
what's your goal you know how are you
even setting this up again under the
Trump Administration when Mike Pompeo
went down there he had a definite goal
uh Mexico you're going to partner with
the us and you're going to help us
protect our borders and if you don't
you're going to see increases in tariffs
you're going to see decreases in aid and
there's going to be a plan put forward
they went down there for nothing more
than a photo op which is exactly what
they got they got schooled Again by the
Mexican leadership and Mexican president
when we were down there a few months ago
uh some of us from ways and means went
down there we met with President oor we
came back with a message that this is a
president who has no interest in working
with the US he is fine to allow as many
illegal immigrants to go through his
country to come into the US he is
fineing with a number of of Mexican
cartels that are doing human trafficking
drug trafficking uh child trafficking
into our country he's got no problem
with that right this was a message that
we sent out months ago and they did not
have a plan they didn't have a strategy
they went down there for a photo op yeah
your governor governor Abbott is tearing
into the Mayors as you know of New York
City Denver and Chicago um and you know
they're complaining about seeing a tiny
fraction of what border communities see
he writes quote the sheer hypocrisy of
these Democrat Mayors knows no bounds
they are now going to extreme lengths to
avoid fulfilling their self-declared
Sanctuary City promises but are silent
as President Biden transports migrants
all around the country and often times
in the cover of night instead of
attacking Texas's efforts to provide
relief to our overwhelmed border
communities these Democrat Mayors should
call on their party leader to finally do
his job and secure the border and that
is a very good point because now you've
got mayor Adams for example here in New
York City that simply just saying you
know this is ridiculous you can't bust
all these migrants to New York City we
need Federal funding um in one day alone
I believe last week there were like 14
buses that arrived here in the city why
isn't he freaking out on the president
because if the president were to secure
the Border then we wouldn't have the
homeless crisis and the illegal
immigration crisis that we've got in New
York City and all these other other
Democratic cities you're asking the
right questions they're just not
answering them and they're assuming that
the American public is stupid we have
been fighting this fight for years in
Texas as a as a former mayor of a city
in North in north Texas I saw this
firsthand and instead of the US
Conference of Mayors and those those
leaders from from some of these largest
of the blue cities instead of them
supporting our efforts instead of what
they do is they fought us they called us
names they called us racist they call
this Hypocrites they call this you know
haters instead of supporting it and this
is what happens when ideology hits
reality they're actually seeing
thousands of of immigrants come into
their into their cities and with a
recognition that they can't support them
we have been saying this for years which
is why under the B Biden administration
number one thing that he did was he
started taking off all the tools from
the table that were working under the
Trump Administration from appearing
nothing more than spite but when you
start thinking about it we have to
understand that this entire play of
what's going on at the border was
planned they were warned what would
happen beforehand if they took things
like Romain and Mexico off the table
they did it recognizing the fact that
you were going to have millions of
illegal immigrants come into our country
and that's exactly what happened we've
had over 10 million folks come into our
country illegally since Biden took over
and by the way over four million of
those have come into Texas so when I
look at what's happening in New York and
in Chicago LA and they're finally
complaining welcome to Welcome to the
party Welcome to our fight instead of
fighting Us in supporting a federal
government and supporting those
Democrats that are supporting these
policies why don't you get on board and
start helping us to change the policies
that are causing all this human
trafficking all this child trafficking
fentanyl deaths and and the push and on
our on our resources in our own country
and start with next election focusing on
who who is actually caring about and
prioritizing the American citizens over
incentivizing those to come into our
country and this is this this is what's
necessary needs a bipartisan push it
just can't be Republican Mayors and
Republican Governors uh and Republican
Senators trying to force Washington to
finally pay attention to this crisis on
the border you need the Democrats to get
on board and the only way to teach the
Democrats that this is a real crisis is
to bring the crisis to their doorstep
and I think it's a great example but it
really stinks for those citizens those
innocent citizens that now have to live
among the mess that these Democrats have
created uh former president Trump's
campaign meantime is slamming President
Biden's handling of the Border in a new
ad watch
this while the world Burns Joe Biden has
created a violent threat in our own
backyard Biden's open border has opened
the floodgates to record numbers
including terrorists fental trafficers
and raises the possibility of a Hamas
attack no seriously I mean the first of
all potential terrorists not to mention
the drugs that are coming over our
border and and and the deaths that are
that are as a result of of of the cartel
basically taking taking advantage of
these open borders what are we doing the
cartels basically own the borders right
now and they're using the Biden
Administration as great Partners to be
able to traffic these people into cities
throughout the country you they're
giving them free bus passes they're
giving them them um train tickets
they're giving them um plane tickets to
get into to into our country further
into our country and that's all paid for
by you know taxpayer dollars so what are
we doing well we passed out of the house
hr2 which is our border security Bill we
are trying to force this Administration
these agencies to do their job but we're
having a fight now a senate that
apparently does not have that same
interest they're trying trying to tie
every other Focus that they have every
priority High spending into their their
focus their priorities as opposed to
protecting our border so Republicans are
fighting for this but you're right it
has to be a bipartisan push we've got to
have the Senate on board and hopefully
you know these Sanctuary cities mayors
that have been have been finally crying
and and recognizing the problem that
we've been talking about for years maybe
they'll have some influence we haven't
seen it yet congresswoman Beth vany
thank you very much for talking to us
always great to hear from you thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley Airhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis